foreign
ERS with a pretty good lineup in they win
the Face-Off and we're underway as Matt
farzell takes the butt for Matthew Robertson
barnesell early on tonight just one shot on
goal that's for the Rangers here's a
giveaway Matt marzell's in all along
Jonathan quick stops a beautiful read watch
him just steal the puck right here right off
the Stick of trocheck everyone's going
one way he's coming the other and there
it is [Applause] [Music] Marzell Corvette
holds Trump playing together here in this
one along shuts it down Jonathan Quick saw that
one too Joe what do you think the expectations
I think they're I think they're high and
I would say this Butch he is getting every
opportunity scores the Islanders take a
one-nothing lead Beautiful beat in front
and it just starts at me and the offense on
the defensive Zone Casio gets it out like a
good quick passes win the battle about driving
wide and watch that show in the middle of your
screen gets a stick out where does he go off
with the target yes get it up over that glove
does Anders Lee who put it right up coaches
or jams will always say you can't skate as
fast as you can pass the puck turn over there
fasting left it for Nelson score thank you
Nelson bashing team up to give the Islanders a
two-nothing lead there's Brock Nelson's first of
the preseason after leading the aisles in goals
each of the last four years a pretty good first
period going uh good job of just keeping the
puck in and bashing with a real nice Between
the Lakes pass oh there's the old five hole he's
going to score across that she's having himself
a pretty good first period and signed the new
contract and says uh hey guys you paid a lot
so it's Trump for his size that's not really
his game more bat on the wrap
around his Scholars what a move
[Applause]
The Islander season is all of a
sudden moved way up because this
is the expectations that everybody is
waiting on us how will those two guys
play together now that they're both healthy
in this first period boy it's been impressive
yeah absolutely and although this team here is
pretty much what will the Islanders will icing
that first I think it was really noticeable
is no adoption played over eight minutes at
the moment the tide can certainly turn but the
Islanders have just been well prepared tonight
owners who did it again all
right he didn't like it either
would fight but but he's certainly going
to pick his spots where he has a chance
to win oh Horvat looking back goes for barzel
nearly completed that one that would have been
a heck of a goal Connie's banging around the
glass in the near side Ross Johnson tries to
dig it for him ship it to the corner Matthew
Robertson out for it the brakes it's away from
Kyle McLean plane out front Hunter button scores
what a feed from Kyle McLean below the goal line
counts Runner Punk with the quick release and
the island the island four-nothing behind the
net we'll take another look like Ross Johnson
is going to go in against the loose puck gets
it in behind the McLean Clutterbuck puts him in
a perfect spot and it's in the back of the mix
yeah there's all the pressure from the Islanders
of course the turnover quick shot beautiful shot
if no one's going to run away from from anybody
I I believe in such great parody of I I still
believe that this Islander team is very capable of
getting themselves in the playoffs and I believe
a lot of these guys are going to have really
big Seasons now if they play defensively like
they have in this game and again they're playing
against you know it is not the full Rangers team
but you know they haven't allowed the Rangers a
shot on goal in the second period so they defended
well and that's led to their offense there's BC
and a cross and Hitler didn't get a lot on loved
it the Forest Circle allenders out shooting the
Rangers eight to one here in the fury and 20-6 in
the hockey game now they just gave Pro check the
the shot after he went around the yeah trying to
stuff it in but that had been about 13 minutes
worth and I want to say that's the best Barley's
best save thus Farney Islanders and we just
start to talk about how good defensible they
are Joe and then they they start to show that uh
they've got some weaknesses out there right now
Carpenter rang it off the iron the referee right
there with his arms out saying it did not draw so
it stays four nothing back the other way former
Ranger Gontier everybody else changing behind
the planes trying to keep it off the Stick
of Harper Ramada with a shot save rebounds
[Music] arzell Horvat holmstrom
and Center ice and the way we go
with the third quick whistle just
six seconds in an Aaron on one side
Holmes from drive and then his shot was off the
glass and then caught part of
the netting goes out of play
One play continue here is lindberan steps and
shoots one in the glove and for lamo might
generate a little bit of offense and here's
trojack with the play and Lindgren all this
chance good save there live our lamov with the
glove and look how aggressive he is Joe I mean
he's look where his feet he hears he's not
just a tough guy good checks all right he's
got a little bit of a nose for offense and
he shoots it pretty hard you know his last
season in Winnipeg before the trade with the
Rangers and there's the Rangers get a goal
Hoffman right there on top of the crease and
he's able to put it in past far along off and
that's one of the real strengths of Brendan
Hoffman is you know the kids he can score
goals he was on the puck all all the time
and he just knocks it down and just whacks
it away and almost not able to cover up on that
short side on the rebound play but the kid just
hanging around and Barley's right there and as
we talked to it also when he feels good about
it yeah yeah yeah I know I meant the contract
yeah bashing takes it away good hard work to
get it to eight ball cruising in and ball will
gather the Loose Change in the corner out Highway
with his shot and that one hit a body it fell
down in front Kyle McLean was gifted a chance
play this look good here in this game tonight has
an assist hell is a worker we can see that he's a
worker bee very much the thesis to zika steinth
players Thomas Sicky alluded to driving to the
net here came off the Stick of that scrub into
the corner of the Rangers making his preseason
debut fed that one down low and head to the bench
started this game with trojack and raw for a year
live you let mixing things up quite a bit
throughout the evening this one's gonna find
the back of that head after a sharp battle just
below the hash marks and it's a 4-2 Islanders lead
sparkly good throw will get that one in second
goal of the period for the Rangers fishing for
the puck really instead of just taking the man Joe
and that eventually causes them a problem [Music]
an unassisted goal Veronica and that group
will hustle to the bench really good play
by Brock Nelson got his feet moving right
away as soon as he had the puck he didn't
stand there and try and do something got the
feet moving not everybody got off an entire
group remained on the ice the Rangers get to it
then one in the final minutes will Cooley yeah
the other night you got to get the puck to the
net it's not like you're looking for one and
there's a little look like almost a misdirection
from brazinski's he just sort of slides it all
the way over watch a little chip bounce yeah and
then the right two of them yeah in the right spot
it to Panera and over the line with Lee in tow
Romanov took a hit got him to clutter but he'll
angle it off the boards to Lee he's got an
empty net to shoot at and he makes it 5-40
Islanders will hang on [Music] xanders lead will
cap up by three advantage in the final 10 seconds
and good moments for the Rangers
too like the game's never over
right now you got two of the kids
that are buying for spots full
score goals the real Cooley against
one Brendan Offman gets one as well